سالفة اشتراط الكفيل الحكومي
وحتى الكفيل الحكومي الظاهر أنكم تشترطون أن ما عليه قروض
كأنكم تقولون لا أحد ياخذ لما تحطون الشروط هذه
هل راجعتوا هذه الشروط؟
هل فيه وسائل أخرى غير سالفة الكفيل الموظف الحكومي أو القطاع الخاص
اللي فيه اتفاقية وهم محدودين جدًّا؟
إيه، شوف الإنزعاج بنسبة جيدة في محله
بس لأسباب مختلفة نوعًا ما
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الأستاذ «إبراهيم بن حمد الراشد»
الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك التنمية الاجتماعية
استعرضنا رحلة هذا البنك من يوم كان اسمه بنك «التسليف»
إلى مرحة بنك «التسليف والادخار»
إلى المرحلة الحالية، مرحة بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
ركائزهم الثلاثة: الحماية، وأيش القروض اللي تقدم في هذه الركيزة؟
ركيزة الاكتفاء، وأيش القروض اللي تقدم تحتها؟
وركيزة الإنتاج
وكيف أن كل هذا الركاز أشبه برحلة
لينتقل الإنسان من الرعوية إلى التنموية
تكلمنا على أبرز التحديات اللي ذكرتوها وأكرمتونا فيها
مثل موضوع اشتراطات الكفيل اللي لازم يكون موظف حكومي
ولازم ما عليه قروض
وسالفة اشتراطات أحيانًا تعقّد الاستفادة من خدماتهم
وتكلمنا كذلك على أهم الفرص اللي استفادوا منها المواطنين
اللي حصلوا على قروض
حتى تكون ملهمة لآخرين قد يستفيدون منها
وفي الأخير طبعًا غطينا مجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
سواءً موظفي البنك أو المستفيدين من البنك
مثل أحيانًا تأخر الاستجابة
أو معدل الرضا المتدني عند بعض خدماتهم
وغيرها من أسئلتكم الثمينة
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
أترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله أبو حمد شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يشرف مقداركم والله، سعيد بشوفتكم
احنا الأسعد
أبو حمد أيش اللي صار في المتوسط وحببك في التقنية؟
المتوسط أنا صدفة أخذت دورة
في الجهاز التعليمي والألعاب في نفس الوقت
وأول أسبوعين تقريبًا استمتعت فيه وكان مبني على الرسومات
وكان لوحة المفاتيح أيضًا متصلة بالشاشة
والشاشة كانت 256 لون فقط
فكان المدرب بعد ما أعطانا فكرة عن الألعاب هذه
شوي أشعل التفكير في ذهننا
قال لنا: كيف هم قدروا يسوون الألعاب هذا؟
كيف أنت تقدر تحرك المربع وتحطه فوق المربع
ثم بعدين تطلع فايز أو العكس
وقال لنا أن فيه أداة برمجية تخليك أنت تصنع مثل اللعبة هذه
فكون الواحد يقدر الحقيقة يتخاطب مع الآلة
ويخليها تستجيب له
واللي برأس الواحد يقدر يخليه يطلع ويشوفه قدامه على الشاشة
في وقتها كان بالنسبة لي سحر
وهي اللي أثّرت على تخصصك وللا لا؟
وهي قطعًا كان تخصصي بكل وضوح
في الجامعة وحتى الدراسات اللي بعد الجامعة؟
صحيح، نازعني شوي بتقنية المعلومات الطيران العسكري
لكن بعدين بالأخير أنا اخترت تقنية المعلومات بكل وضوح
ودخلت في حالة هوس بموضوع البرمجة وموضوع التقنية
وما قدرت أتخلص منه إلى اليوم
وتعتقد أنه كان قرار صحيح؟
الحمدلله، شوف الناس اللي درسوا تقنية المعلومات بالثمانينات قبلي
أنا درست تقنية المعلومات بدايةً بعام 1991
كل الجيل هذا هو كان الجيل الذهبي
للتغييرات اللي صارت في العالم بسبب التقنية
لذلك كان لديهم فرصة الحقيقة أنهم يطوعون خبراتهم
ومعلوماتهم لصالح التغييرات في القطاعات كلها
وعملت بعدها في أكثر من مكان
وأكثر من جهة حكومية وخاصة من زاوية التقنية
بس أنا مدخلي لمحور حلقتنا بيكون
أيش الفرق بين العمل في بنك تجاري اللي هو بنك «الراجحي»
والعمل في بنك تنموي مثل بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
اللي بيكون محور حديثنا
أيش الفرق بين البنكين؟
فيه فروقات نوعًا ما في رسالة الحكومة مقارنةً ببنك تجاري
فيه توقعات من ملاك البنك ومن حملة الأسهم
و أيضًا فيه توقعات من العملاء أنفسهم
الحكومة في البنك عادةً
تأسس البنوك التنموية حتى تقدم خدمات للعملاء
اللي مش لاقين الخدمات هذه في البنوك التجارية
وهذا موجود ومشاهد في كل دول العالم
لأن في شريحة دائمًا في المجتمع
الشريحة هذه ماهي قادرة توصل للخدمات المالية الرسمية
أو فيه خدمات أخرى مكلفة جدًّا على البنك التجاري
البنك التجاري ما يبغى يدخل فيها
على سبيل المثال تمويل المنشآت الصغيرة والناشئة
في مرحلة التأسيس ما يقدمها أي بنك تجاري
لأنها عالية المخاطر
لأن مخاطرها جدًّا عالية
تقريبًا نسبة الفشل في الشركات الناشئة
اللي يأخذون تمويل أكثر من 50% عالميًّا
فبالنسبة للبنك التجاري لو دخل فيها
راح يخسّر نفسه، وراح يخسّر أيضًا ملاك الأسهم
وملاك البنك في نهاية الأمر
فالتوازن بالنسبة له ما يستقيم بهذا الشكل
الحكومة تنظر لها بنظرة مختلفة جدًّا
الحكومة تقول أنا عندي الناس هذولي هم عائلتي في النهاية
أنا راح أقرض ألف واحد على سبيل المثال يفتحون ألف شركة
الـ 500 شركة اللي نجحت هذه
هي تغطي من ناحية أثرها الاقتصادي وخلقها هذه الوظائف
تغطي الـ 500 الثانين اللي أخفقوا خلال خمس سنوات من عمرهم
فهي رسالة تنموية مش رسالة تجارية
وما دامنا بدينا بالكلام عن البنك التنموي
عطنا تاريخه، ووين وصلنا اليوم في بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
البنك أُسس في عهد الملك فيصل الله يغفر له ويرحمه
في فترات متقاربة مع البنوك التنموية الأخرى
الصناعي والزراعي و غيرها
حتى صندوق الاستثمارات العامة في ذاك الوقت
يبدو كثير من المؤسسات المالية انطلقت في السبعينيات
صحيح، هي الدولة الحديثة في تأسيسها
في بدايتها كان في نهاية عهد الملك سعود
وبداية الملك فيصل الله يغفر له ويرحمه، واستمرت
والبنك بدأ بداية لطيفة الحقيقة
البنك بدأ كأنه منشأة ناشئة
رأس ماله كان قريب من الـ 5 ملايين ريال، هذه بداية البنك
لكن كانت رسالته واضحة
هي رسالته اللي يسمونها تغطية ما يتعلق بالشمول المالي
اللي توّ حكيت أنا عنها
اللي هو أنها توصل للناس اللي تشملهم ماليًا
لأن هم صاروا خارج دائرة الخدمات البنكية التجارية
وكان اسمه بنك «التسليف»؟
وكان اسمه بنك «التسليف» وبدأ تحديدًا في عام 1972
وبعدين استمر طول السنوات السابقة هذه كلها
والحقيقة كل مرحلة تجي يكون فيه ضخ في رأس مالها
يكون فيه توسّع أيضًا في منظومة منتجاتها
الين الحمدلله رب العالمين، وصل اليوم رأس مالها إلى 45.500 مليار
ويعتبر هو أكبر بنك تنموي
يقدم قروضه للأفراد المحليين في الشرق الأوسط
بنسولف عن واقع البنك اليوم
بس فيه مرحلتين في الماضي يهمني أن أسمع عنها
مرحلة اضيف له كلمة الادخار، بنك «التسليف والادخار»
أيش هذه المرحلة؟ وليش هذه الإضافة؟
ومرحلة الدخول على المنشآت
أنتوا كنتوا تاريخيًّا تخدمون الأفراد
بعدين فجأة بديتوا تدخلوا على المنشآت
اللي في 2007 على ما أظن
لو تحدثني عن هذه المرحلتين
يمكن زمنيًا نبدأ بالمنشآت
المنشآت مثل ما تفضلت بالـ 2007 بدأ
وسبق المنشآت فكرة أن هم يموّلون
الأفراد اللي يبغون يشتغلون كباتنة بسيارات الأجرة
واشتغل البنك فيها وموّل أكثر من 15 ألف سيارة أجرة
وبعدها بالـ 2007
اللي هي أفراد يشترون سيارات؟
نعم، وكان معروف وكان في ذيك الأيام
وعندنا كانت صور تاريخية لها
كانوا حتى يحطون مثل الطبعة عليها بنك «التسليف»
وبعدين في 2007 البنك توسع وقال
ليش أنا ما أُطلق أيضًا برنامج
أموّل فيه المنشآت الناشئة
وأُلزمهم أيضًا بأن يأخذوا التدريب اللازم قبل يبدون مشروعهم
كانت هذه شرارة البداية
والحمدلله استمر البنك على النحو هذا، وعلى التوسع هذا
الادخار قصة شوي مختلفة
الادخار بدأ من أن البنوك التجارية
وهذا يرجعنا لنفس النقطة اللي قبل شوي قلتها أنت
بالنسبة لحملة الأسهم ما لهم مصلحة تجارية كثير
في إطلاق حساب ادخاري
والحساب هذا يوزع أرباح بناءً على الموجودات
ما لهم مصلحة فيها
لأن العملاء هم تاركين أصلًا فلوسهم في الحساب الجاري
فتقاسم الأرباح معهم يمكن ماهو في صالح حملة الأسهم
لذلك تلاقي بالعالم كله مش حتى بس بالسعودية
لما تروح لحساب التوفير تلاقي يعطيك نسبة بسيطة جدًّا
تخلي الواحد يقول ما يسوى أني أربط المبلغ في حساب ادخاري
في الحقيقة من سبع سنوات تقريبًا كانت بوضوح
وضع الادخار بالسعودية كأدوات وكمنتجات؛ يعتبر قاصر
صار فيه لجنة شُكلت
لجنة عليا لدراسة الموضوع هذا، البنك عضو فيها
وبدأت تعمل على إعداد استراتيجية للادخار
البنك الحمدلله كان من أكثر الأعضاء الفاعلين
بناءً على الرؤية اللي تبلورت وتكونت
وأيضًا بمبادرة من البنك
لأن الاستراتيجية لا تزال تحت الاعتماد
البنك أطلق منتجه الأول وسمّاه «زود» الادخاري
وأطلقناه احنا على نفس النمط وكأن هو منشأة ناشئة
نبغى نجس نبض العملاء
وكيف سلوكيات العملاء تِجاه الادخار
والتحدي كان كبير
لأن احنا نبي العميل اللي مقترض مننا
نبيه يسدد ونبيه يوفر في نفس الوقت
هل بيقدر عميل...
إجمالي دخل الأسرة يمكن أقل من 8000 ريال
اجمالي الدخل كله 8000 ريال
ومقترض من عندنا، وأيضًا بيفتح حساب ادخاري ويبي يوفر فيه!
واحنا نراقب الحساب هذا، كان هذا تساؤل كبير
بدينا بشكل مبسط والنتيجة كانت جدًّا رائعة وعظيمة
راح نسولف عنها في المحور الثاني حكايتها
ما زلت أنا بحاول أفهم هذا الكيان
فنحن اليوم نتكلم عن بنك «التسليف»
ثم بنك «التسليف والادخار» ثم بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
صحيح
خلينا نبدأ من هنا
ليش تغيّر الاسم؟ وأيش الأشياء اللي وراء تغيير الاسم؟
اللي وراء تغيير الاسم بكل تأكيد هي الرؤية
الرؤية أعطت قيادات البنك، أعطت مجلس إدارة البنك
أعطت أيضًا التنفيذيين في البنك
جرأة عالية جدًّا على التغيير
لو نرجع ونتأمل في رسائل سمو ولي العهد الله يحفظه
رسائله تراها واضحة جدًّا
أجمل رسالة هنا أتذكرها ودائمًا ترن في ذهني
لما كان يقول بصراحة أنا ما عندي وقت
وكان يتطلع إلى أن الأجهزة الحكومية هذه كلها
اللي كانت في يوم من الأيام ماهي حزمة وحدة
كان يتطلع على أنها تكون تكمل بعضها البعض بوضوح
وأن كل مؤسسة حكومية تقفز ولا تسير
شوف إحساس الجرأة هذا انتقل إلى الجهات الحكومية
انتقل للبنك
من فضل الله، مجلس الإدارة والإدارة التنفيذية وفريق البنك
استجابوا بشكل سريع جدًّا
بس ما فهمت أنا أيش التغيير؟
أيش بالضبط التغيير اللي صار؟
التغيير مثل ما تفضلت أنت، كان العنوان في البداية في تغيير الاسم
ثم بعد ذلك المحاور اللي تغيرت
تقريبًا كل محاور البنك تغيرت
من أيش لأيش؟ أيش كان وأيش صار؟
البنك كان سابقًا تركيزه الأساسي على رعاية الناس
تحوّل البنك إلى أن يكون ممكّن اقتصادي
مش فقط رعاية اجتماعية وتسهيل سبل حياتهم
أو تخفيف مصائبهم وإلى آخره المالية، وهذا مستمر
تحوّل أيضًا وتوسع بشكل ضخم جدًّا أن يكون ممكّن اقتصادي
كان نسبة القروض اللي نقدمها التجارية أو الإنتاجية كانت 10%
اليوم هي أصبحت قريب من 70%
و90% اللي كانت، كانت عبارة عن أيش؟
90% كانت اجتماعية
ممكن تعطينا أمثلة؟
مثلًا أشهر قرضين للبنك هو قرض «الأسرة»
اللي يُقدم للأسرة بناءً على دخلها وإجماليه وعدد أفراد الأسرة
والثاني قرض الزواج
البنك ضخ في القرضين هذه تقريبًا قريب من 90 مليار
تاريخيًّا في الفترة السابقة هذه كلها ، لما بدأت...
تراكميًّا؟
تراكميًّا صحيح
وخدم فيها أيضًا قريب من 3 ملايين مواطن ومواطنة بشكل مباشر
إذا أخذنا أولادهم بعين الاعتبار اللي استفادوا، اللي معهم بالبيت
نلقى العدد يصل إلى 10 ملايين مواطن ومواطن
استفادوا من قروض البنك
دخول القروض الإنتاجية اللي هو قرض العمل الحر
وقروض أيضًا المنشآت
غيّر التوجه اللي أنت تسألني عنه
إلى أنه مش بس يكون اجتماعي ومراعاة للناس
لا، أنه يكون نبغى الناس توقف على أقدامها
احنا نساعد الناس حتى يساعدوا أنفسهم
بدل ما يكون هو اليوم تحت خطر محدودية الدخل
أن يكون مكتفي عن طريق العمل الحر
مستقل يشتغل أو أسرة منتجة
إذا أيضًا نجح كمستقل وكأسرة منتجة
ينتقل إلى المستوى الثاني اللي هو يكون منتج
وبالتالي يفتح أيضًا مؤسسة، ويفتح شركة ناشئة صغيرة
ويكون بدل ما يوظّف نفسه؛ يوظّف أيضًا غيره
وهذه ركاز البنك اللي تغيرت بشكل محدد
عُرّف البنك يمكن أوضح النقطة هذه بالأخير
أنه صار فيه ثلاث ركائز
ركيزة الحماية، البنك عُرف فيها تاريخيًّا
ركيزة الاكتفاء، هي موجهة للمستقلين والأسر المنتجة
وركيزة الإنتاج، الموجهة للـ «إس إم إي»
والبنك الحقيقة في كل الثلاث ركائز اليوم هو الأكبر في الشرق الأوسط
لا من ناحية إجمالي القيمة، ولا من ناحية إجمالي العملاء
ولو بتكلم على حوكمتكم
أنتوا أيش علاقتكم بالمنظومة؟ مين مرجعكم؟
أيش أهم أهداف استراتيجيتكم؟
الاستراتيجية مركزة على التنمية الاقتصادية
وعلى خلق الأثر الاجتماعي الاقتصادي
وهذا ساعدنا كثير، لأن احنا مرتبطين تنظيميًّا بصندوق التنمية الوطني
وهو الصندوق اليوم اللي تحت مظلته
كافة الصناديق والبنوك الحكومية
الصندوق الوطني عنده أهداف إجمالية محددة مرتبطة بالرؤية
وأيضًا مرتبطة بخطط القطاعات نفسها
مثل القطاع الصناعي، القطاع التعليمي، القطاع الصحي، إلى آخره
فهو يُسقط الأهداف هذه على الصناديق
والصناديق حسب الاختصاص تبدأ تقرض
وتجتمع بعدين النتائج كلها عند صندوق التنمية الوطنية
وعلاقتكم بوزارة الموارد البشرية والتنمية الاجتماعية
هل فيه علاقة؟
علاقة قوية على مستوى البرامج
لأن فيه كثير من الشرائح اللي احنا نخدمها
هي أساسًا شرائح تحت مضلة
الوزارة؟
وزارة الموارد البشرية، الشؤون الاجتماعية سابقًا
فلذلك برامجنا تقريبًا
ما نطلق برنامج إلا واحنا متأكدين
من أن المعلومات المكتملة
والتكامل على أعلى مستوى
ولو بنتكلم على أهم ما تحقق في ركائزكم الثلاثة
الحماية، الاكتفاء، والإنتاج
أيش أهم ما تحقق في كل واحدة منهم؟
الحماية احنا مستمرين في رصد
مع وزارة الموارد البشرية مع رصد الاحتياجات
مع حد الكفاية بالنسبة للعملاء
وحدة من أهم الأشياء اللي صارت
أننا رفعنا حد الكفاية من 12 ألف للأسرة إلى 14500 للأسرة
أيش هو هذا الرقم؟
هذا هو رقم الحد الفاصل للأسرة المستحقة لقرض الأسرة أو لا
إذا الأسرة أكثر من 14 ألف
هي ما تدخل عندنا إطلاقًا
ويدخل أيضًا تحت الـ 14 ألف
بمعادلة معينة كم عدد أفراد الأسرة
هذا كان تغيّر جوهري
بالإضافة طبعًا إلى أننا غيرنا أسلوب التقديم
وأسلوب الصرف من أسبوعين، ثلاثة أسابيع
إلى أنه صار ثلاثة ساعات تقريبًا باستخدام التقنية
القروض الاجتماعية كليًّا عملاءنا ما يجونا
يعتمدون فيها على المنصة الحكومية
هذا قرض الأسرة؟
هذا القرض الاجتماعي ككل
القروض الاجتماعية بشكل عام كلها
إيه بس عشان اللي ما يعرف عن القرض هذا
أيش فكرته؟ ومين يستحقّه؟
هو قرض الأسرة مثلما قلت لك
بناءً على الحد اللي تستحقّه الأسرة
أي أسرة سعودية دخلها أقل من 14 ألف تستحق؟
تستحقه
مرة وحدة؟
مرة واحدة كل سنة
على حسب حالتها أيضًا الاجتماعية اللي تتقدم فيها
ويدخل فيها عدد أفراد الأسرة، على سبيل المثال
إذا الأسرة مكونة من زوجين و14 ألف إجمالي دخل الأسرة
ما تستحق لأن ما عندهم أطفال
فاحنا ندخّل فيها اللي نسمّيه نصيب الفرد
فنصيب الفرد اللي هو لكل فرد تقريبًا 2000 ريال
ندخّلها بالمعادلة
وكم حجم القرض هذا؟
حجم القرض 60 ألف
60 ألف؟
صحيح
ويسدد على كم سنة؟ أو على كم شهر؟
يسدد على خمس سنوات، بما مقدار ستين شهر تقريبًا
القصد 1000 ريال شهريًّا
وعليه فوائد؟
ما عليه فوائد، القروض الاجتماعية مجانية
مجانية؟
صحيح
كم شخص استفاد من هذا القرض؟
استفاد تقريبًا 2.8 مليون
بشكل مجمّع على سنوات كلها
وهذا تشرطون فيه كفيل موظف حكومي؟
هذا يجب يكون فيه كفيل موظف حكومي، أو يكون كفيل
وهذه فتحناها احنا في السنة الأخيرة
من القطاع الخاص من الشركات المرتبطة معنا باتفاقيات
وهنا كان فيه بعض الأسئلة اللي وصلتنا
بما أننا فتحنا الموضوع
كان فيه انزعاج كبير من هذا الشرط
اليوم فيه أدوات كثيرة لقياس الائتمان
ولقياس القدرة على السداد
سالفة اشتراط الكفيل الحكومي
وحتى الكفيل الحكومي الظاهر أنكم تشترطون أن ما عليه قروض
كأنكم تقولون لا أحد يأخذ
لما تحطّون الشروط هذه
هل راجعتوا هذه الشروط؟
هل فيه وسائل أخرى غير سالفة الكفيل الموظف الحكومي
أو القطاع الخاص اللي فيه اتفاقية وهم محدودين جدًّا؟
شوف الانزعاج بنسبة جيدة في محلها
بس لأسباب مختلفة نوعًا ما
شوف البنك يقرض سنويًّا قريب من 170 ألف مواطن ومواطنة
سنويًّا مستمرين؟
سنويًّا إيه، ومعظمهم ترى يجيبون كفلاء
احنا ما نشترط أن الكفيل يكون ما عنده قروض
احنا بس نشترط أن الكفيل والعميل أيضًا
قروضه ما تتعدى الحد المخصص من البنك المركزي
اللي هو 33% - 60% على حسب نوع الاقتراض
عقاري أو غيره
لكن لو يجينا عميل على سبيل المثال هو واصل 60%
والكفيل معاه واصل 60%
ماهو في صالحهم صراحة، ولا في صالح البنك أن يقدّم لهم
لسبب بسيط: أن مخاطر تعثرهم عالية
ولو تعثروا البنك يجب يسترد مبالغه
البنك ممكن أن يأجل مرة أو مرتين أو ثلاثة
بس في النهاية راح يُرهق المقترض
لأنه ما كان مستعد الحقيقة للاقتراض هذا
بالنسبة للكفيل الحكومي
هذا الانزعاج اللي أنا أتكلم عنه اللي هو صحيح
احنا كنا فيما سبق نشترط
يجب أن يكون كفيلك حكومي أو أنت تكون موظف حكومي
اليوم تقريبًا من ستة أشهر إلى سنة
بدينا تدريجيًّا بفتح الباب للقطاع الخاص
فالشركات اللي منضوية معنا وموقع عقود واتفاقيات معنا
بالعكس نقبلهم كعملاء ونقبلهم ككفلاء
على نفس هذا السياق أنا أتذكّر جاني سؤال من أحد موظفين «أس تي سي»
يقول: احنا من أكبر الشركات
وحاولنا أكثر من مرة التفاهم معهم على اتفاقية
لكن دائمًا يجي الرفض، أنه لازم يكون كفيل موظف حكومي
عندك اطلاع على قصة الاتفاقية مع «إس تي سي» أو شيء؟
لا بالعكس، احنا عندنا قناة جيدة مع مجموعة «أس تي سي»
هل هم من الجهات اللي موقعين معهم في اتفاقية؟
أعتقد فيه اتفاقية جاية معهم قريبًا
بس لسّه ما صار؟
صحيح
هذا قرض الأسرة وفهمناه
أيش فيه قروض أخرى اجتماعية ضمن ركيزة الحماية؟
عندنا قرض الزواج
وقرض الزواج هذا ما مقدار تقريبًا 60 ألف ريال أيضًا
وبنفس الآلية، يتم تسداده على مدى خمس سنوات
من يستحقّه؟
يستحقّه الزوج خلال سنتين من زواجه
الفترة هذه يستحقّه
بعد مضي سنتين ما عاد يستحق القرض هذا
وقبل الزواج عشان يستخدمه في الزواج أيضًا ما يستحقّه؟
قبل توقيع العقد صحيح ما يستحقّه
وكيف تتعاملون مع سالفة لا سمح الله الطلاق اللي يصير في أول أشهر
وللا في البدايات؟
هل أنتم تشترطون انتظام معين؟
وللا هو مباشرة يكون مستحق للقرض؟
لا هو مستحق للقرض
مجرّد ما يكون معه عقد زواج احنا نتفاءل معاه
أن الله يوفقه هو وزوجته ونقدّم القرض
وفيها كفيل هذه برضه؟
نفس الشيء كفيل حكومي؟
إذا ماهو موظف؛ نعم فيها كفيل حكومي
إذا مو موظف حكومي؟
إذا مو موظف حكومي لازم يجيب كفيل حكومي
أو من الشركات اللي وقّعنا معها اتفاقيات
تمام. غير قرض الزواج؟
على فكرة الاتفاقيات مع الشركات سهلة ماهي صعبة
هي الاتفاقية تقول
الشركة هي مثل الاتفاقيات بين البنوك التجارية والشركات
أن الشركة الموارد البشرية جوّا الشركة
ملزمة بمكافأة نهاية الخدمة
إيه
إضافة لالتزامات أخرى طبيعية
بحيث أن البنك يضمن حقه فيها
أنا أتفهّم صراحةً الموضوع اللي واصل حد من القروض عالي جدًّا
لأنك أنت تحميه بأنك ما تعطيه قرض
وليس فقط حماية للبنك
لكن بأمانة ماهو مقنع بالنسبة لي سالفة اشتراط الكفيل الحكومي
احنا نتكلم على شرط، حتى البنوك التجارية
اللي هي أكثر حدةً منكم ما تشترطه
المنتظر من بنك التنمية أن يكون أكثر مرونة
مع الشريحة الأكثر حاجة اللي عادةً ما يلقون حاجتهم عند البنك
فهذا بالنسبة لي صراحةً إلى الآن مو مقنع
لكن أنتم أبخص مثل ما يقولون
أيش فيه قروض أخرى اجتماعية تقدمونها؟
أقدر أساعدك في الإقناع يمكن
ياريت والله
البنوك التجارية على فكرة ما احتاجت للكفيل
لأن راتب الموظف نفسه ينزل عندها
الموظف موقّع عقد معها، وهم موقّعين اتفاقية
مع الجهة الحكومية أو الشركة
أن راتب الموظف ينزل في البنك
البنك يأخذ حقه والباقي
يحوّله للموظف
فهي عندها أداة أقوى من الكفيل
وأنتم ما  لقيتوا حل إلا موضوع الكفيل
لا، طبعًا احنا بحكم أننا في النهاية صندوق حكومي
ما عندنا موجودات ولا عندنا حسابات للعملاء
بس مثلًا «سمة» تصنيف ائتماني، شخص قاعد يسدد فواتيره
قاعد يسدد قروضه، تصنيفه الائتماني جيد جدًّا
ألا يُحسب هذا كضمان مقبول بالنسبة لكم؟
يُحسب، يساعد لكن ترى ماهو ضمان
شوف البنوك التجارية اللي تقدّم قروض
بضمانة «سمة» نسبها السنوية 7%
نسب التعثر؟
نسب الفائدة
أها 7%؟
7% نتكلم عن تقريبًا أكثر بست أو خمس مرات
5% أو 6% من القرض الشخصي الموجود في البنوك
لأنهم يعوّضون
قطعًا فيه نسبة كبيرة هي متعثرة راح تكون في «سمة»
ما تستمر متعثرة
هذه القرضين، أيش فيه غيرهم في موضوع الحماية؟
فيه «قرض كنف» أيضًا تستحقّه المطلقات والأرامل
فيه قرض لـ«الترميم»
وفيه عندنا اتفاقيات احنا نسوّيها مع بعض الجهات
اللي عندهم فئات خاصة على سبيل المثال
فئات الأيتام
عندنا برامج خاصة أحيانًا نوقّعها
هدف عام لبعض، مو شريحة عامة ولكن شريحة مخصصة
مثل مثلًا المعاقين وغيرها
هذه أيضًا نحاول نساعدهم احنا
أتذكّر لك مقابلة في مارس 2020 إذا ماني بغلطان، أو حولها
وكنت تتكلم على موضوع قرض «الترميم»
أنتم وقفتوه بتعيدون هيكلته
على شكل شراكة مع مهندسين متقاعدين من «أرامكو» أو شيء مثل كذا
هل صار شيء على هذا الموضوع؟
صار بشكل محدود
شوف احنا نحاول نلاقي جمعيات تساعدنا
على أداء مهمة البنك من خلال الوصول للناس
البنك ما يقدر يوصل لمنازل الناس بشكل مباشر
ولو البنك توسّع بالعمل هذا
طلع عن دوره كمقرض
فاحنا نعتمد على القطاع الثالث والجمعيات أنها تساعدنا
فاحنا نجحنا جزئيًا مع وحدة من الجمعيات
فيما يتعلق بالفكرة هذه، ونتمنى والله نوسّعها
لكن طموحنا أكبر من كذا
أنتم مستمرين في هذا القرض وللا موقفينه؟
لا «الترميم» مستمر
مستمرين؟
إيه مستمر «الترميم»
وأيضًا عندنا تعاون مع «سكني» ومع غيره
وكأني فهمت من أسئلة الناس أن قرض العلاج وقفتوه وللا لا؟
كان فيه قرض للعلاج في الخارج أظن أو شيء مثل كذا ووقفتوه
أنا ما أعرفه القرض هذا؟
مافي قرض كان للعلاج؟
مافي قرض
قد يكون تاريخيًّا موجود بس ما يحضرني
مو الفترة القريبة هذه؟
لا، لا أبدًا
هل فيه أي نوع من أنواع المنتجات وقفتوها في مرحلة التحوّل هذه؟
مافي شيء توقف من حيث النوع
لكن فيه تحوّل صار
على سبيل المثال قرض الناشئة اللي احنا كنا نقدمه
هذا القرض كان يقدّم 300 ألف لرواد الأعمال
ويشترط عليهم نوع معيّن
وياخذ مننا حدود ثلاثة إلى خمسة شهور إجراءات
غيّرنا القرض هذا، وغيّرنا العلامة التجارية حقه
سميناه من ناشئة إلى رواد الأعمال
ورفعنا القيمة إلى 500 ألف
وصارت المدة الزمنية لها أقل من شهر
لصدور القرار؟
لصدور القرار ومعظمها ترى هي بس لجاهزية العميل
ففيه تغيرات صارت في العلامات التجارية
وفيه تغيرات كبيرة في العمليات والتحول الرقمي داخل البنك
لكن ما أعرف أنا أن فيه قرض كليًّا احنا وقفناه
هذه كلها نماذج لموضوع الحماية
وأنا أتذكّر في سوالفنا قبل كم يوم
على نسبة التعثر، وأنت أعطيتني نسبة صراحةً مبهرة
في نسبة التزام هذه الشريحة، شريحة محدودي الدخل
في الوفاء بالتزاماتهم
كم كانت نسبة التعثر اللي قلت لي إياها
عن قروض الحماية هذه؟
ممتازة جدًّا الصراحة
احنا عندنا نسب التأخر تقريبًا 3-4%
هذولي الناس اللي يتأخرون عن السداد
وعندنا تقريبًا 0.5% هم الناس اللي يعجزون عن السداد
تعتبر نسبة ضئيلة جدًّا قياسًا بعالم الإقراض بشكل عام
البنوك التجارية وضعها طبعًا أفضل
لأن البنوك التجارية ترى ما تقرض الفئة هذه
لكن أيضًا هذا يعطينا مؤشر على أن الفئة هذه عندها التزام
رغم صعوبتها
واحنا كمختصين أيضًا في البنك ومطّلعين
ذُهلنا أن الفئة هذه قدرت تسدد، ومستمرة تسدد
وقادرة أيضًا توفر عن طريق برنامج «زود»
كنا نشوف الاحصائيات
احنا عندنا اتفاقية أن نشوف أداءهم الادخاري
فكيف أسرة دخلها الإجمالي أقل من 8 آلاف
عنده طفل أو طفلين مقترض من عندنا، ويوفر أيضًا فلوس
يدل على أن الشريحة هذه الحقيقة
محل والله احترام وتقدير
ومن فضل الله الحكومة ما قصّرت فيما يتعلق بالمخصصات
دائما تحافظ عليها
آخر سؤال في هذه الشريحة قبل ما نروح للركيزة الثانية
كيف توازنون ما بين حماية مصالح البنك
لأن في النهاية هو مال عام
لهذه الشريحة ولغيرهم من شرائح تستحق الدعم
فأنتم عليكم مسؤولية استرداد هذه الأموال
فكيف توازنون بين هذا الدور
وبين عدم مضاعفة الضغط على هذه الشريحة
اللي هي شريحة أكثر حاجة، شريحة محدودة الدخل
دفعة وحدة ممكن تكسر هذه العائلة وتشتتها
وشلون توازنون بين تحصيل جيد
وعدم الإضرار بهذه الشريحة؟
البنك تاريخيًّا معروف يمكن لكافة المناطق
لمعظم المواطنين معروف
خصوصًا في المناطق خارج المدن الرئيسية
البنك عنده أربعة وعشرين فرع
جزء كبير من دور الفروع تفهّم حالة الناس
تفهّم احتياجات الناس
أيضًا الحمد لله البنك قادر على أن يوجد صيغة لتأجيل السداد
متسامحة جدًّا مقارنة بالبنك التجارية للفئة هذه
فلذلك احنا قناعتنا أن الناس قادرة على السداد
معظم الناس قادرة على السداد، لكن تحتاج وقت
تحتاج أيضًا إلى توعية باستمرار
فيما يتعلق بأنه يجب سداد القرض
وإذا فيه لا سمح الله ظروف طارئة
القرض ممكن يكون فيه له تأجيل
وحتى لو وقع خلّني أقول أننا عملنا «متخلف عن الدفع»
على العميل في «سمة» وللا غيره
فيه أيضًا أسلوب آخر ممكن نتخذه للتخفيف على العميل هذا
فيه شراكة مجتمعية بين البنك وبين المواطنين
لك أن تتخيل بعض المناطق
نسبة اللي اقترضوا من بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
تشكّل حوالي 22% من المنطقة
22% بالنظر للسكان في المنطقة هذه كلها
22% من سكان المنطقة اقترضوا من البنك
صحيح
وفيه سنوات سابقة عُملت إحصائية على سبع سنوات
للناس اللي تزوجوا
من سجلات وزارة العدل
وأخذنا السجلات هذه، وسوّينا إحصائية، كم منهم أخذ قرض؟
لقينا حوالي 60% منهم أخذ قرض من البنك
ففيه الحقيقة شراكة جدًّا ممتازة
وأنا أعتقد فيه تفهّم عند الناس بالالتزام هذا
لأن المبلغ اللي احنا نستردّه
احنا نرجع مرة ثانية ونعطيه
فكل واحد يعجز عن السداد هو يؤثر أيضًا على العميل
والحكومة عندها الحمد لله رب العالمين
قدرة على التغطية بشكل جدًّا ممتاز
في الركيزة الثانية اللي هي الاكتفاء
أيش أبرز ما تحقق؟
الاكتفاء ركيزة تقريبًا جديدة
باستثناء ما ذكرناه في الموضوع السيارات
وبدايات الناشئة
والركيزة هذه أساسًا هي جديدة
في السعودية كلها
شوف معالي رئيس مجلس الإدارة
المهندس «أحمد الراجحي»
من أربع أو خمس سنوات تقريبًا في مراجعاته لسياسة العمل
كان فيه قناعة عند الوزارة
أنه يجب أن نتحرر من فكرة أن الموظف في قوة العمل
هو الموظف بدوام كامل
الموظف ممكن يكون بدوام جزئي، ممكن يكون بدوام مرن
وممكن أيضًا يكون بالعمل عن بُعد
وهذا انعكست حتى على موضوع التأمينات الاجتماعية
على موضوع التأمين الطبي
كل اللي يعملون بشكل منفرد ماهم مشمولين في التنمية الاجتماعية
ولا في التأمين الطبي في مرحلة سابقة
صحيح
فكل هذه تم ضمها ضمن مجموعة سياسات في الوزارة
أيضًا الوزارة تبنّت تأسيس شركة خاصة
لخلق أنماط العمل الحديثة
الشركة اللي هي شركة «عمد المستقبل»
الشركة هذه اليوم عندها أكثر من مليونين
شهادة خلقتها هي لممارسي العمل الحر
معظم الفعاليات اللي في السعودية نشوفها اليوم
كثير اليوم من الشركات هم قاعدين يستعملون
السياسات اللي هي العمل المرن أو العمل عن بُعد
بشكل سهل وعن طريق المنصات القائمة
هذا تزامن أيضًا مع أن البنك يبغى يتوسّع
في تقديم قروض للناس اللي ودّه يبدأ من بيته
أو يبدأ بشكل شخصي
على بال ما يكوّن نفسه ويفتح شركة ناشئة
فالفئة هذه كلها احنا حطّيناها تحت مسمّى العمل الحر
تحت مسمّى الاكتفاء
وقدّمنا القروض لهم  اللي هي...
أيش أنواع القروض اللي تقدمونها لهم؟
نقدّم لهم 120 ألف قرض العمل الحر
وقرض السيارات كان أيضًا بنفس القيمة تقريبًا
ورفعناه إلى 300 ألف أيضًا
لخدمة فئات مختلفة من السيارات
والحمد لله صار عندنا طاقم ضخم جدًّا
يشتغل في «أوبر» و «كريم» سيدات وشباب
وأيضًا عندنا طاقم ضخم جدًّا من الأسر المنتجة موجودين
وكلهم يتم زيارتهم بشكل دوري
مين يستحق الـ 120 ألف هذه أو القرض هذا؟
مين مؤهل له؟
مافي عليها حد معيّن من ناحية مثل الحد الاجتماعي
هو مؤهل له الشخص اللي يقدر يعبّي النموذج
ويتأكد فعلًا أن عنده اهتمام
بمجال معيّن، وفيه تصنيفات معينة للعمل الحر
وأيضًا ما عنده مشكلة مالية هو
إذا كان أيضًا بلا عمل يكون فرصته أفضل
إذا كان عنده عمل احنا نساعده على زيادة دخله
إذا كان عمله محدود براتب له حد معين
فهذه هي الفئة اللي احنا اليوم
فكل المواطنين والمواطنات مؤهلين
لقرض العمل الحر
صحيح
وإذا كان غير موظف فهذا يزيد استحقاقه
هذا يزيد استحقاقه
وإذا كان -طال عمرك- من الضمانيين أيضًا يصبح له مزايا أكبر
وهذا مربوط بشركات معينة؟
هل هذه شراكة بين «أوبر» و «كريم»؟
بحيث أن هذا الشخص أول ما يشتري السيارة يكون معاهم؟
وللا أيش طريقة ضمانكم أن يحقق من وراءها دخل يرجع ويسدد لكم؟
سجلات الشركات هذه مختلفة
من ناحية أداء العملاء
فلما وقّعنا احنا عقودنا
في البداية كان مع «كريم» وبعدين مع «أوبر» قديمًا
وبعدين وقّعنا أيضًا مع منصات أخرى مختلفة
ما اقتصرت بس على النقل الموجّه
حتى على التوصيل وعلى غيره
فكان فيه قاعدة بيانات بالنسبة لنا تعطينا ارتياح
أن الناس عندها أداء ممتاز
وما زلنا احنا نطّلع على أداء عملاءنا
من ناحية قدرتهم على الوصول وعملهم بالسيارات
لكن ركيزة الاكتفاء ركيزة مهمة بالنسبة لنا احنا
لأنها هي تجسّرنا احنا
بمثابة الجسر للعملاء
من أن يكون يعتمد على نفسه ويشتغل من بيته
سواءً كفرد أو كأسرة
إلى أنه بكرة يقدر يفتح سجل تجاري
وينطلق للفئة الثالثة اللي هي فئة الإنتاج
كم عدد الأشخاص اللي استفادوا من هذا القرض؟
فوق 300 ألف عميل تقريبًا
وما يزال الحمد لله احنا سنويًّا
نصرف على حدود 40 ألف - 50 ألف عميل
سنويًّا؟
سنويًّا
عميل جديد؟
عميل جديد، نعم
تحملني معليش بس هذا من ضمن الأسئلة
نرجع لموضوع الكفيل
هنا يسألون عن السيارة باسمكم
وتقدرون تسحبونها وتبيعونها مباشرة
فليش كفيل غارم؟ ليش كفيل غارم حكومي؟
فيه توسّع كبير في موضوع السيارات
ولو تشوف حتى قروض البنوك التجارية فيما يتعلّق بالسيارات
تلاقي نسب الإقراض اللي يفرضونها على العملاء جدًّا عالية
تتجاوز أحيانًا 7%
لأن ماهو سهل جدًّا تغطية تكاليف استرداد السيارة
أو بيعها لا سمح الله خردة
أو حتى التأكد منها ونقلها لعميل آخر
هذا يجر خلفه تكاليف جدًّا عالية
احنا وضعنا فقط الشرط هذه للتأكد من جدية العميل
أن العميل عازم فعلًا على أن يشتغل
وراح يظهر لنا في سجلات المنصات
إلى أنه قاعد يسوّي مشاوير ونتأكد منها
فهي بالنسبة لنا نقطة مهمة جدًّا على موضوع الالتزام
وعندنا اتفاقيات على فكرة مع بعض المنصات
عندهم كان رغبة وأن هم يكونوا يلعبوا دور
الكفالة بنسبة معينة تخفف على العملاء
أبرز استخدامات قرض اكتفاء لو بنساعد الناس
أنهم يستفيدون من الفرص الموجودة
احنا قلنا سيارات، أيش فيه غيرها في موضوع العمل الحر
حسيتوا أن الناس يأخذون القرض ويستفيدون منه
في هذا القطاع أو المجال؟
الأسر المنتجة، الأسر المنتجة اليوم وصلوا حدود 150 ألف أسرة منتجة
عادةً يحتاجون في بداية إنتاجهم مبلغ كبير حقيقة للتأسيس
سواءً كان عملهم في مجال الأطعمة وللا في مجال الخزفيات
وللا في الحرف وللا تنظيم الحفلات على مستوى صغير
كل هؤلاء يحتاجون رأس مال في البداية
فاحنا عندنا قصص نجاح عظيمة جدًّا بالنسبة للأسر المنتجة
والله أنا حبّيت الإهداء اللي أكرمتوني فيه
هذا كان أسرة منتجة وللا لا؟
هذه أسرة منتجة
إيه، وذوي احتياجات خاصة؟
وأيضًا ذوي احتياجات خاصة
وهذا شيء ملهم، لما تشوف الشخص
والإنتاج أو المشغولات اللي سواها أو سوّتها
كانت جدًّا -ما شاء الله- ذات جودة جيدة
صحيح
ما شاء الله عليهم المستوى عالي جدًّا
جدًّا ولاحظنا احنا في آخر ثلاث أو أربع سنوات تقريبًا
صار فيه إدراك عند الأسر
ترى أنتِ أسرة منتجة مو معناها أن الناس تشتري للمساعدة
لا، الناس صارت اليوم تبغى أيضًا منتج ممتاز
الأسر نفسهم كانوا يقولون أنا أيش اللي يميزني عن الأسرة الثانية؟
إذا أنا بطبخ أيش يميزني؟
إذا أنا بقدّم حلا أيش راح يميزني؟
فيه بعض الأسر تقدّم حلويات اليوم بدون سكر أبيض
فيه بعض الأسر تقدّم حلويات
مآخذين دورة في فرنسا قبل لا يقدمون حلويات
المعجنات، فيه أسر الحقيقة أنا أتفاجأ فيهم
عنايتهم بالجودة اللي هم يقدمونها
بدون الأسلوب هذا راح يكون عملهم تقليدي
وبالنسبة لهذولي يبدو لي أنتم قدمتوا لهم برضه خدمة
في موضوع تشغيل المقاهي في الجهات الحكومية
أو شيء مثل كذا وللا لا؟
صحيح
لو تعطيني القصة؟
يمكن هذا من أبرز المشاريع
والظاهر مشروع آخر أتكلم عنه
احنا لاحظنا يمكن كلنا لما نراجع الدوار الحكومية
نلاقي فيه كافتيريا
يوم كنا نراجع الدوائر
الحين ما عاد نراجعها
الحين ضغطة زر ونخلّص
محدودة
لكن احنا قلنا حتى الموظفين حق الدوائر الحكومية اليوم
ليش ما نخلّي الأسر المنتجة المتميزة
هي اللي تدير المقهى داخل الجهة الحكومية هذه؟
والحمد لله رب العالمين احنا وصلنا لأكثر من 120 فرع الحين
تحت علامة تجارية اسمها «يمام» خاص بالبنك
ومعنا أيضًا شريك يساعدنا في الجودة
وفي قائمة الطعام وإلى آخره
هدفنا كان هدفين الحقيقة
واحد، عشان نبيّن أن الإنتاج ممتاز
اثنين، لاحظناها احنا كنمط أن الأسرة تجي وتشتغل
وبعد يمكن ستة شهور
تشوف الدخل اللي قاعد يصير تتحسّف أن مو كله لها
فتطلع تفتح مقهى أو فرع خاص فيها هي
وهذا هو ترى الهدف الرئيسي من «يمام»
وكيف نموذج العمل؟ كل أسرة تمسك لها فرع
وللا توزعونهم على شكل موظفين؟ وشلون مسوّينها؟
احنا كل أسرة أو إذا كان مثلًا فيه بنتين مختلفتين
حبّوا أنهم يشتركوا فيها؛ يكون هم اللي متولّين الفرع هذا
المعيار حق العمل من البنك تقريبًا بمساعدة شريك مختص
وبالتالي يبدون يشتغلون
ما حبّينا أننا نكثّر التغيير
لأن أيضًا لازم يكون عندهم فريقهم الخاص
وأيضًا النكهة حقهم لازم يستمر فترة طويلة
لين العميل نفسه يقتنع فيه
لكن بطبيعة الحال بالنسبة للعمل هذا
هم يتغيّرون
وكيف تقسيم الأرباح بينكم وبينهم؟
احنا نلزمهم طبعًا أنهم يودعون 10% من الأرباح
في حساب البنك، والباقي للأسرة
10% من الإيراد وللا من الربح؟
من الإيراد
من الإيراد 10% هذه مقابل أيش؟
هذه مقابل أن كل شيء متأسس لهم، والتدريب لهم
وأيضًا البداية في البضاعة
كبداية أيضًا البنك يساعد فيها
وهل المشتريات والمواد الغذائية هذه عليكم وللا عليهم؟
لا عليهم
عليهم هم؟
صحيح. هو الهدف أنه يدخل إن صح التعبير دورة في واقع الحياة
ويبدأ يشتغل تحت احتضان مؤقت
وبعدها احنا مؤمنين أنه بيكون أفضل مننا
بيخلق تجربته الخاصة
وسوّيتها في موضوع المقاصف في المدارس وللا ما سوّيتها؟
مقاصف المدارس سوّيناها جزئيًا على شكل مشاريع
كان لنا تجربة في المنطقة الغربية
تجربة جيدة في منطقة مكة
وكان فيه تجربة محدودة صارت في الحدود الشمالية
ليش ما توسّعتوا؟ ما نجحت؟
معقّد الوضع والله
وشلون؟
عندك مستويات -خلنا نقول- من الإدارة معقّدة
عندك مدير المقصف جوّا المدرسة، وفوقه المدرسة
وكيل وفوقه مدير المدرسة، إيه
وفوقه إدارة التعليم
ويدخل فيها أيضًا الصحة والسلامة
أنا أعتقد أن وضعه كان يحتاج إلى شركة كبرى
أن تدير العملية هذه بشكل
والأخوان بالتعليم أعتقد عندهم دراسات في هذا الموضوع
فهذه ركيزة اكتفاء، وهذه أهم القروض والتطبيقات اللي طلعت فيها
نروح للركيزة الأخيرة، اللي هي ركيزة إنتاج
أيش أبرز ما تحقق فيها؟
الإنتاج، بس أنا ودّي أرجع إلى ركيزة اكتفاء
لما سألتني أنت عنه «يمام» فيه نقطة ثانية
اللي هي التدريب المتخصص، عفوًا ودّي أرجع لها
تفضّل
احنا لاحظنا فيه فئة من الأسر المنتجة
فئة ما عاد يكفيها التدريب العادي
لذلك من تقريبًا سنة وشوي أطلقنا مجموعة خطط تدريبية
وصرنا نوفّر مدربين عالميين لمجالات معينة
الأيام هذه احنا عندنا ثلاث مدربين
جايبينهم من فرنسا خاصين بخلط العطور
لو تشوف اليوم الأسر المنتجة اللي تشتغل في مجال العطور
ترى 80% إنتاجهم تقليدي
تلاقي عندها حلم، وبرأسها شيء تبغى تحققه لكن
ماهي قادرة
ماهي قادرة تسوّيه
ما عندها المهارة اللازمة
فيه نقص
الـ 20% أيضًا هذولي يا تلاقي عندهم مشكلة في التغليف
يا تلاقي عندهم مشكلة في... إلى آخره
قليل ترى من السعوديين اللي عنده علامة تجارية
وتوقيع عطور
فمجال العطور هذا اليوم فيه مدربين
جبنا احنا مختصّين أيضًا في التزيين للأكل
مش لإعداد الأكل، فقط التزيين
كيف أنت لما تقدّم الوجبات أو تقدّم المنتج
يكون أيضًا بشكل جميل
جبنا للجلود وجبنا مجموعة من الحُلي والمجوهرات
وكلهم مدربين عالميين نجيبهم
يقعدون عندنا أسبوع أو أسبوعين
بورشة عمل كاملة ويكتسبون
ومعظم أو كل تقريبًا اللي موجودين ما بين ناس محترفين
سعوديين وسعوديات أو متوسطين
ونسبة منهم أيضًا عندهم منشآت
فالعمل الحر الحقيقة الآن اللي بحاول أوصل له أنا
دخل في مرحلة الاحترافية
ما عاد يكفي أنك أنت فقط قوة عاملة جاي تقول
أنا أقدر أساعد، لا، احنا نبغى منك قيمة إضافية
معايير منافسة موجودة
صحيح
وهذا يدخّلني على سؤال كان في بالي
غير الفلوس، هل تقدّمون شيء أبعد من ذلك؟
بمعنى لما تعطيني قرض زواج
هل تساعدون هؤلاء الأفراد في موضوع
مهارات إدارة الأسرة، التفاهم، حل الخلافات الزوجية؟
هل تأخذ هذه الخطوة، نفس الشيء في الموضوع
أنت ذكرت لنا أمثلة على ركيزة اكتفاء
فالسؤال العام هو
مع قروضكم المالية هل تعطون شيء أبعد من المال؟
صحيح. فيه برامج في البنك خاصة
للتأكد أن القرض هذا يسانده خطة تنفيذية من العميل أساسًا
وبالتالي على سبيل المثال كل قروض المنشآت الناشئة عندنا
التدريب فيها مُلزم ماهو اختياري
ويجب أن يقدّم لنا أوراق كافية تثبت
على أنه واعي وين رايح تقريبًا
وهذا كله للتخفيف على المخاطر المالية
وعلى مخاطر أيضًا الفشل على العميل
الأسر المنتجة تقريبًا كلها متاح لها
عن طريق شركاؤنا أنهم يأخذون تدريب في مجالاتهم
أيضًا نحن نتيح لهم أنهم يدخلون في برامج البنك التسويقية
والبنك يقيم سنويًّا حدود 280 فعالية
في مختلف أرجاء السعودية
اليوم الوطني على سبيل المثال
احنا نقيم أكثر من تسعين فعالية متزامنة في نفس اليوم
في تسعين منطقة ومدينة وقرية في نفس الوقت
الفعاليات هذه كلها احنا نقدّمها للأسر
برسوم رمزية لاختبار الجدية أيضًا
وهذا كله يمكّنهم أنهم مش فقط قرض وإنما قرض وتمكين
بس أنا أقصد كمراحل قياس أو تدريب لمهارات حياتية
مثلًا قرض «الأسرة» لو صاحبه دورات عبر الإنترنت
في موضوع إدارة المصروفات
أو الاستثمار، أو الادخار، أو أي نوع من المهارات المالية
اللي بتساعد هذه الأسرة اللي أخذت القرض
أنها بعد القرض ما عاد تحتاجكم إن شاء الله
لأن هذه ركزة حماية
فماهو بالضرورة يكون وضعه أحسن بعد ما سدد القرض
الزواج نفس الشيء، المهارات الحياتية، مهارات العلاقات
وفي النواحي الإدارية والتشغيلية في موضوع المنشآت
وقروض العمل الحر
هل فيه أشياء من هذا النوع؟
أتذكّر برنامج «سند»
الأمير «محمد بن سلمان» والمنح اللي تُقدّم لشرائح معينة
كانت دائمًا تربط باكتساب مهارات حياتية
تساعد هذا المستفيد من المنحة أن يكون في وضع أحسن
بعد انتهاء أثر المنحة المال
هل فيه أشياء مثل كذا؟
فيه شغلتين
وحدة، الإدارة المالية موجود فيه دورات مستمرة
بالتوعية المالية للعملاء كلهم
وهي أطلقناها بالتزامن مع موضوع الادخار
هي جزء من موضوع الادخار
الثاني، في حدود علمي أيضًا أن الوزارة عندها تدريب
تقدمه في موضوع الزواج
سواءً للمقبلين على الزواج أو المتزوجين
أو للي عندهم صعوبات في أثناء الزواج، وهي متاحة لهم
واحنا كنا في فترة سابقة
ولا يحضرني الآن إذا كان البرنامج مستمر أو لا
نشترط على جزء من العملاء أنهم يأخذون التدريب هذا عبر الإنترنت
الركيزة الثالثة الإنتاج، أيش أبرز ما تحقق فيها؟
والله الحمدلله، الإنتاج هي تقريبًا مصدر فخر
صارت لنا في السنوات الأخيرة
البنك اليوم سنويًّا يحقق أرقام قياسية
في عدد المنشآت اللي يتم تمويلها
أيضًا البنك فخور أنه يموّل منشآت
المنشآت هذه ماهي قادرة تقترض من البنوك التجارية
فاحنا أوجدنا نمط وأسلوب لتقديم التدريب
ولتقديم التمويل، ولزيارة العميل أربع مرات في السنة
حتى احنا نتأكد من أداءه
وأيضًا لتقديم بعض المعلومات والمساعدات للعملاء
وعندنا أيضًا إمكانية فترة سماح للعملاء تصل إلى سنة ونص
لما نقدّم له القرض
تعطيه فرصة إلى أن يؤسس مشروعه ويبدأ
الركيزة هذه الحمد لله رب العالمين كان أثرها جدًّا ممتاز
هذه 500 ألف ريال صح؟
هذه بالنسبة للمنشآت الناشئة 500 ألف ريال
كم استفادوا منه؟
الشركة الناشئة الصغيرة
إذا الشركة الناشئة نعتبره احنا يبغى يبدأ
وهو شركة صغيرة مش متناهية الصغر
فيكون السقف 4 ملايين
عندنا عيادات على سبيل المثال
عيادات أسنان، مختبرات، عيادات عيون
فتحت في المناطق وبأعداد كبيرة جدًّا بالمئات
من قرض التميّز اللي هو إلى 4 ملايين
وبعضها توسّع، فتح له عيادة إضافية من قرض القائم
اللي يصل إلى 10 ملايين ريال
وهذولي كم عدد المستفيدين؟
الآن الحمد لله رب العالمين احنا قرّبنا من 42 ألف منشأة
ما شاء الله
البنك موّلها
السنة هذه من نِعم الله، وأيضًا حقيقةً إبداع فريق البنك
راح نحقق تقريبًا 11 ألف منشأة تم تمويلها
هذا أكثر بـ 30% من العام الماضي
العام الماضي كان استثنائي بحد ذاته أساسًا
ما شاء الله. وهنا أنتم تعطونها قروض مجانية
وللا بنسبة فائدة؟
نأخذ عليها رسوم تشغيل
رسوم تشغيل؟
صحيح
وكيف مقارنتها بالبنوك؟
عندنا التوجيهات اللي احنا نتّبعها أن نقريبًا الرسوم
تكون تعادل 50% من الرسوم التجارية
اليوم «السايبر» وصل إلى 6%
البنوك تصل الآن في إقراضها للمنشآت
إذا كانت منشأة بالنسبة لها منشأة جديدة
مافي سابق علاقة بينها تصل إلى 12-18%
إذا المنشأة عند البنك التجاري لها علاقة مسبقة
ومربوطة بنقطة بيع، ممكن تصل إلى 5%
لأن عميل قديم لهم نوعًا ما
فبناءً عليه احنا نسعّر رسومنا
فأنتم نصف تقريبًا اللي موجود في البنوك التجارية
صحيح. ولا نروح للفئة التجارية الرابحة 100%
نحاول نبعد عنها
أيش نوع التكامل أو التعارض اللي بينكم
وبين برنامج كفالة وبنك المنشآت
اللي مفترض أنه موجّه لهذه الشريحة؟
كفالة مختلفة تمامًا
كفالة تحاول أنها تحل مشكلة الكفالة عند الشركات
لكنها ما تقدّم قرض، اللي يقدّم القرض هو البنك التجاري
بضمانة كفالة
وأيضًا معظم توجههم من حيث القيمة للشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة
لكن احنا جهة إقراض مباشر مش جهة كفالة
بنك المنشآت، احنا كنا في اللجنة التأسيسية لبنك المنشآت
بنكها مشارك في اللجنة التأسيسية
وما يزال البنك في مرحلة التأسيس
اليوم بنك التنمية الاجتماعية هو المشغّل
لبرنامج التمويل الخاص ببنك المنشآت
ومتفائلين كثير الحقيقة الفترة القادمة
لأن حجم الطلب ضخم جدًّا
لك أنت تخيل البنك يخدم قريب من 10% - 15% من المتقدّمين
الباقيين يا إما يدخلون بالشريحة نفسها
أو يضطرّون يقبلون برسوم عالية من البنوك التجارية
أو ما يقبلون البنوك التجارية
أنا أعتقد بنك المنشآت راح يكون له دور جوهري
أتوقّع أن هذا القطاع كله بيروح لبنك المنشآت؟
أنا أعتقد القطاع معظمه من النوع هذا بيروح لبنك المنشآت
البنك مستمر في خدمته لمنشآت متناهية الصغر
والشركات الناشئة الصغيرة
بنك المنشآت اليوم يحاول يغطّي الفجوة
اللي تتجاوز 200 مليار سنويًّا
حسب هيئة الإحصاء، وأيضًا دراسة هيئة المنشآت
أيش نوع الضمانات اللي تأخذونها على هذه الشريحة؟
شريحة المنشآت
المنشآت نوعًا ما وضعنا أفضل، أوسع من الأفراد
إذا كانت المنشآة جديدة، ما عندها تدفقات نقدية
فنلزمها احنا بضمانات
شخصية؟
كاملة شخصية، أو إذا عنده ضمان آخر عقاري
أو نرجع مرة أخرى للوسيلة الأخرى، اللي هي وسيلة الكفيل
هذا إذا كانت المنشأة جديدة تحت التأسيس
إذا المنشأة قائمة وعندهم آخر سنتين تدفقات جيدة
احنا عادةً ما نلزمهم بكفالة
نكتفي فقط بسند لأمر على المُلّاك
حتى لو إدارة المسؤولية محدودة؟
حتى إيه. أهم شيء أنها تكون شركة صغيرة فأقل
أيش تعريفكم لشركة صغيرة فأقل؟
احنا نتّبع التعريف مع هيئة منشآت
اللي هو أعتقد أربعين موظف، أو 40 مليون ريال تقريبًا فأقل
بالنسبة للصغيرة
هذولي أيضًا تقدّمون لهم برنامج «دُلّني» صح؟
صحيح
لو تحدثني على البرنامج هذا؟
«دُلّني» بدأ كريادة أعمال في البداية
تعرف عندنا مشكلة مع الشركات الناشئة
يمكن احنا كلنا دخلنا في الجانب هذا على المستوى الشخصي
الواحد يصير عنده إيمان أكثر من الواقع
فلما يحط رجله في الميدان يتعرّض لنكسات إن صح التعبير
بسبب المنافسة، بسبب توقعات العملاء، إلى آخره
عادةً 80% من الشركات الناشئة يحرق النقد اللي عنده في أول سنتين
في هذه المرحلة يبدأ شوي يفقد البوصلة
ويفقد الأساسيات حق العمل
ويرجع يكرر نفس الأخطاء اللي وقع فيها الآخرين
الحالة هذه هي اللي حقيقة كوّنت فكرة ولادة «دُلّني»
فـ «دُلّني» ولد من تقريبًا ثمان سنوات في الحدود
كريادة أعمال، وكان أول دورة يقدمها وما يزال
من أهم الدورات أنا أعتبره، اللي هو العودة إلى أساسيات الأعمال
وأنا أتفاجأ دائمًا، لما يجون الناس اللي لهم سنتين يشتغلون
ويدخل بالدورة هذه يتذكر
أنه كيف ضيّع الأساسيات هذه من البداية
وليش هو الآن، تمام السوق قاسي
لكن أيش ممكن هو يسوّي؟ إلى آخره
«دُلّني» ممتازة جدًّا في الجانب هذا
أيضًا «دُلّني» كويسة في التخصص، تسوّي فعاليات خاصة
مثلاً تسوّي فعاليات لمحلات القهوة
صنّاع التجارة فيها وتجمع ثلاثين أو أربعين واحد وسوّتها في مكان واحد
وتخلّيهم يقدّمون أيضًا مشورة لأصحاب المشاريع الأخرى الموجودين
وليش شركة مشغّلة؟
ليش مو أنتم اللي تسوونه؟
ترى الشركة ماهي مشغّلة كليًّا
الشركة تشغّل، لكن وفق خبرة متراكمة عندنا احنا
لذلك فريق اللي موجود في «دُلّني» اليوم هو نفس الفريق
حتى لو تغيرت الشركة المشغّلة لأن الفريق نفسه
الشركة اللي تجي الجديدة تستقطب نفس الفريق
كونه بالفعل صار
أضف إلى ذلك معظم أعمال «دُلّني» هي متطوعين
متطوعين؟
معظمهم. ويكاد يكون مافي أحد أعرفه
هو مركز صح؟
هو مركز تحت البنك، ولكن احنا معطينه شوي حرية صراحةً
نحاول نخلّيه يطلع بأفكاره الخاصة
ونحرره شوي من الحوكمة الشديدة الموجودة عندنا
من ناحية خلق المنتجات والوصول إلى الناس
من الأسئلة اللي لفتت نظري أحد الأشخاص المنزعجين من الموضوع
أرسل يتكلم عن أن شركة مشغّلة متحكمة في المشروع
وتعاملها ماهو جيد مع الموظفين
انسحب 70% من موظفين المركز خلال سنتين
إلى أي مدى هذا الكلام دقيق؟
والله شوف الشركات طبيعتها ترى رواتبها مو مثل رواتب
الجهات الحكومية أو الشركات الحكومية
بس هو على قد ما أنتم تعطونهم
بيعطون الموظفين اللي عندهم، وللا لا؟
وفي نفس الوقت «دُلّني» بالنسبة لنا هو
مكان جذب للطاقات العالية جدًّا
إذا استقرّت الطاقات هذه
وأنا أعتقد لو ترجع لثلاث سنوات أو أربع سنوات سابقة
بتلاقي نسبة كبيرة منهم انتقلوا إلى أماكن أفضل
فهو «دُلّني» يعتبر هو بالنسبة لنا احنا
مكان فيه حرية أكبر نشتغل احنا فيه
الموظفين، فيه نسبة كبيرة من الموظفين يبحث عن الاستقرار
يبحث عن النوع من العمل النمطي الموجود
«دُلّني» ماهو من النوع هذا
«دُلّني» شوي فيه قسوة في العمل
ولذلك طلعوا الـ 70%؟
وبعضهم مستمر، بعضهم مبسوط وعنده نسبة الحماس جدًّا عالية
بس هي في بيئتها نوعًا ما أكثر حدة
من بيئة البنك ومن كثير من البيئات
الملاحظة في محلها الحقيقة
ما دامنا نتكلم عن الموظفين، لاحظت أن عدد الموظفين انخفض عندكم
من 1500 تقريبًا إلى 1200 أو حدودها
وقلت لك أنا قبل ما نصوّر
أن عندي رسائل مرة متضادة جاتنا على الحلقة
من أشخاص يشوفونك بطل، ملهم، رائع
وينقلون لك شكرهم
وأشخاص يشوفونك ظالم، قاسي، حرمتهم من امتيازاتهم وحقوقهم
لما سوّيتوا التسكين
فأي واحد أبو حمد؟
شوف لما بدأنا احنا في التحوّل
كان عندنا قناعة في مجلس الإدارة والإدارة التنفيذية
وأيضًا الفريق ككل
احنا عندنا إن صح التعبير مركبتين
هي اللي راح تقود التحوّل هذا
المركبة الأولى الموارد البشرية
الناس أنفسهم والفريق نفسه
المركبة الثانية كانت التقنية
إذا البنك يبغى يتغيّر؛ لازم الثنتين هذه تتغيّر، لا بد
الموارد البشرية كان بوضوح
إذا احنا كنا نبغى ننتقل إلى بنك مستدام
وبنك حجمه ضِعف ماهو حجمه اليوم
وأيضًا بنك يخلق اقتصاد
فأنا لازم أستقطب ناس على كفاءة جدًّا عالية
لا يقلّون عن كفاءة البنوك التجارية
لكن هم موظفين حكوميين اليوم موجودين
وفق السياسة الموجودة
فكان أول قرار صراحةً هو أن ننظر للقلب هذا نغيّره
القلب اللي هي سياسة الموارد البشرية
فاحنا الحمدلله رب العالمين
احنا تقريبًا وقبلنا بفترة بسيطة بدأت هيئة الزكاة
احنا وهيئة الزكاة تقريبًا أول جهة حكومية بدأت في التحوّل
فأخذنا موظفيننا كما هم وعملنا لهم تقييم
وتأهيل وتحويل إلى نظام العمل
نظام التأمينات، أسوةً بالقطاع الخاص
غيّرنا السياسة حق الموارد البشرية
أوجدنا علاوة تصل إلى ست رواتب
كثير من المدراء اللي كان يدير محافظ بالمليارات
وراتبه 17 ألف و18 ألف تحوّل راتبه إلى 70 ألف
إذا كان كفء وقادر عليها
إذا هو مو كفء وقادر عليها تحسّن نسبيًّا
احنا استقطبنا أيضًا شخص عندك خبرة بهذا المجال من قبل
الموظفين اللي ما كان عندهم رغبة
أو كان عندهم فرصة يأخذون صك ذهبي
قدّمنا لهم أيضًا صك ذهبي
ولذلك انخفض العدد انخفاض كبير جدًّا
الموظفين الآخرين ألحقناهم ببرامج تدريبية
البنك يأخذ ثلاث سنوات
يمكن ضاعف حجم التدريب عنده للموظفين
أكثر من خمس مرات
وكلها لدعم الموظفين اللي ما عنده مشكلة استعداد للعمل
بس عنده فقط نقص فني في بعض المهارات اللي يحتاجها
مافي شك فيه موظفين بالنمط الحكومي يشوف
أنه تم التعدّي عليه، هو كان موظف حكومي آمن على سلّم حكومي
واليوم هو صار منكشف في عقد
ولكن أيضًا بالمقابل صار فيه إدراك مؤخرًا عند الأغلبية الساحقة
أن هذا توجّه الحكومي كله
اليوم الحكومة في معظمها تقريبًا تشتغل بالعقود
ما عاد فيه المراتب السابقة سابقًا
وأساسًا التوجّه الحكومي صار هو توجّه فعالية
يعني أنا أبحث عن...
مثلما أنا قاعد أضع الآن أهداف ممتازة وطموحة جدًّا
يجب أيضًا أستقطب موظفين قويين
أو أبقي على موظفيني القويين
ولازم أيضًا يكون عندي وسيلة للمحاسبة قوية
ولازم يكون عندي مكافآت في نفس الوقت
شوف الخليط هذا يخلق عندك الفئتين هذه
الفئة المنزعجة، والفئة أيضًا اللي تعتبر حقيقة
واللي استفادوا من التحوّل هذا
بدون أدنى شك هم العدد الأكبر بالنسبة للبنك
الموارد البشرية أنا أتصوّر هي خلف قصة أي نجاح
والله لا الميزانية بتساعدك
ولا التخطيط بيساعدك
ولا إذا عندك أنت هدف سامي ممتاز بيساعدك، ما راح يساعدك
اللي بيساعدك أن عندك موظفين ممتازين
إلى درجة أنهم قادرين يحولون لك الصعوبات
والتحديات والمشاكل إلى فرص
وهذا احنا شفناه اليوم
اليوم أنا شخصيًّا لمست الآن ثمرة التحوّل هذا
على المستوى اللي أنا أشوفه
فضلًا عن الأرقام اللي تتكلم عن نفسها
أنا شخصيًّا اليوم تقريبًا ربع وقتي فاضي
بكل أمانة، فاضي للبنك يعني أقدر أني أجي أقول
هل عندي فرص إضافية؟
غير المكينة اللي تشتغل القائمة اليوم
عندي فرصة أني ألتقط النفس وأسمع للعملاء؟
عندي فرصة أجلس مع الشركاء وأبحث عنهم
هذا كله بفضل الموارد البشرية حقيقةً
مش لأنني وقّعت عقود مع شركات تسوّي شغلي، أبدًا
هذه ممكن تحوس الشغل الشركات هذه
صار عندي قدرة على التفويض
عندي ست قياديين في البنك ماسكين القطاعات
أربعة منهم هم النوّاب، والباقي قطاعات أقل نسبيًا
الحقيقة كل واحد منهم يعرف في مجاله أكثر من ما أنا أعرف
عندنا مصفوفة صلاحيات
أنا أزعم أنها واحدة من أفضل مصفوفات الصلاحيات
اللي فيها تفويض حقيقي للناس
لما تجلس مع النوّاب أيضًا تلاقي النوّاب تحته صف ثاني
تحت النوّاب صف ثاني أنا فخور فيه الحقيقة
وكنت دائمًا أقول للزملاء في النوّاب
يجب أن وقتك أنت 25% يكون فاضي
حرفيًّا أبغاك تكون فاضي، جاهز لأي طلب يجينا
لأي فرصة نلتقطها احنا
دخول أي نائب في التفاصيل مؤشر على إن صح التعبير
أسلوب التحكم في الإدارة
ما عندنا كان عذر لما تحوّلنا الموارد البشرية
أني أجيب ناس ممتازين خبراء في الصف الثالث
أعطيه الصلاحية أن هو يشتغل
واحنا نركّز على الفرص الكبيرة
نركّز أيضًا على جعل البنك في مصاف البنوك التنموية
ويا ربي لك الحمد، اليوم البنك بفضل الله ثم الفريق نفسه
قاعد يتحقق إنجازات كبيرة
أنا فعلًا آخر سنة، حقيقةً آخر سنة أتفاجأ ببعض الشغلات
وأسعد فيها أنها تطلع داخل البنك
أنا ما فكّرت فيها على مستوى الشخصي
وأعرف أن النوّاب ما فكّروا فيها على المستوى الشخصي
وأعرف أنهم بدلوا جهد فيها بسيط
لدرجة أن أحد النوّاب كان يقول لي
احنا نجي الآن ونقص الشريط وذا
صراحةً الشباب هم اللي خلقوا هذه الفكرة وهم اللي انطلقوا فيها
وهذه يمكن واحدة من آثارها، جميع ما سبق أقصد
أن أنتم تحولتم إلى الاستدامة المالية
كنتم سابقًا معتمدين على دعم حكومي سنوي
صحيح
لو تعطينا كذا لمحة على وشلون تحولتوا إلى الاستدامة المالية؟
الاستدامة على سبيل المثال ما كنا بنقدر
نصل للمرحلة اللي اليوم احنا فيها
إلا بموارد بشرية أيضًا قوية
قوية من ناحية تطوير المنتجات، ومن ناحية الاستثمار أيضًا
البنك عنده مكينة استثمارية ممتازة جدًّا
تساعد على تغطية الخسائر اللي تصير
أنتم تستثمرون رأس المال؟
وأيضًا إيرادات، نعم إيه
اللهم لك الحمد احنا البنك تقريبًا في الست سنوات الأخيرة
حققنا إيرادات كاملة للبنك
محققة وغير محققة، أقصد نقد أو مؤجلة
تتجاوز 6 مليار ريال
هذا كله بجهود البنك تقريبًا
وهذا كله على أساس البنك يوقف على أقدامه
ويستغني عن خزينة الدولة
وكان هذا واحد من أهم الأهداف اللي بالرؤية
أن التنظيم هذا الآن
هل يجب أنها تكون مستدامة وللا ما يجب؟
البنك يجب يكون مستدام، هو بنك في النهاية
وإن كان بنك تنموي
إلا أن المفروض أنه يكون ذاتي التمويل، ذاتي التشغيل
فالحمد لله رب العالمين، بدأناها من أربع سنوات تقريبًا
بشكل شرس فيما يتعلق بالاستدامة
لا على مستوى الرسوم، ولا على مستوى الاستثمار
وفي نفس الوقت متدرّج
لذلك احنا ما عندنا أي رسوم على العملاء تتجاوز 50% من السوق
بالنسبة للمنشآت، وبالعكس احنا عندنا الآن بعض المنتجات
في المنشآت أصبحت تقريبًا 25% من سعر الإقراض في القطاع الخاص
عندنا أيضًا الخزينة والاستثمار الحمد لله
أصبحت عندها إبداع قوي جدًّا
وحققنا فوق 4.5 مليار تقريبًا
وتساعدنا على تعويض الخسائر الائتمانية الموجودة
احنا نغطّي الوفاة للعملاء
وأيضًا نغطّي التأخير للعملاء
ونغطّي الـ 0.5% العاجزين عن السداد للعملاء
فهذا كله يساعدنا فيما يتعلق بالجهد المتعلق بالاستدامة
وبالنسبة لكم أنتم نتائج البنك وأرقامه ليست للنشر؟
أنتم ما تشاركونها مع المجتمع بشكل سنوي، تقرير سنوي
موضوع أداء البنك، ومصروفاته، وإراداته، ما تشاركونها؟
لا بعكس موجودة في الحسابات الختامية
بس هل هي منشورة للمجتمع؟
صحيح إيه
وين نلقاها؟
في موقع البنك
موقع البنك، نتائج السنوات السابقة؟
صحيح
من التحولات أيضًا موضوع الفروع
أنا تشرّفت بدعوتكم وزرت «جادة ثلاثين»
واللي يبدو أن فيه منها عدد ماهو بسيط في أنحاء المملكة
حدثني عن اللي صار في تحويل فروعكم
هذه قصة الحقيقة احنا فخورين فيها
فخورين فيها أنها حصلت بهذا الشكل السريع
وأيضًا أنها كانت محل دعم كبير من مجلس الإدارة
معالي أبو فهد «أحمد الراجحي» لما تكلمنا على فروعنا سابقًا
من خمس سنوات
كانت القناعة أن احنا في عالم الآن رقمي
ليه نكلّف على الناس أنها تجي للفرع؟
أن الفروع ما عاد لها احتياج اليوم
فكان أمامنا خيارين: يا نقفّل فروعنا
أو نحوّل فروعنا من أنها تكون فروع موظفين يخدمون العملاء
إلى أنها تكون فروع لإقامة العملاء
وقُدّمت في حينها الدراسة
وكانت الحمدلله الدراسة واعدة جدًّا
أن احنا نمشي على فروعنا كلها، في سبعة عشر منطقة
ونحوّلها كلها إلى فروع
حاضنات أعمال، مسرّعات أعمال ومكاتب أعمال
خاصة بالعملاء، مش لنا احنا
يكون فيه في الخلف مكتب بسيط لموظفيننا لإدارة ما بقي من أعمال
أيضًا البنك في قطاع التسويق
هو قطاع مبدع قطاع التسويق في البنك
معظم أعمالنا ذاتية
ابتكروا اسم «جادة ثلاثين»
أيضًا الزملاء في الخدمات المشتركة، في الهندسية
ابتكروا تقريبًا كلما يتعلّق بالمبنى، فكرة المبنى
فكان جهد ضخم جدًّا صار من مجموعة داخل البنك
وكأنها شركة ناشئة داخل البنك اشتغلوا عليها
حوّلنا الفروع اليوم نجحنا في ست فروع تقريبًا
في الرياض، بريدة، الدمام، خميس مشيط، الجوف، وفي تبوك
ومقبلين أيضًا على ست فروع أخرى قريبًا إن شاء الله راح نفتحها
أنت تدخل الفرع ما تلاقي موظفين، تلاقي شركات ناشئة
الشركات الناشئة هذولي موزّعين على تصنيفات معينة
فيه منهم اللي يحتاج فقط إلى طاولة
فيه منهم اللي يحتاج إلى مكتب
وفيه منهم اللي يحتاج إلى خليط من كذا
بالإضافة للتسهيلات الثانية اللي نقدّمها لهم
البيئة بيئة جدًّا ممتازة، حتى أنّي كنت أقول للزملاء
خلّونا نعقد بعض اجتماعاتنا في الجادّة
احنا نروح نكتسب منهم شوية طاقة
بس هنا ما حطّيتوا نص السعر
هنا حطيتوا سعر السوق، هويلين شوي
احنا في الجادّة الحقيقة
شوف الأخوان في هيئة منشآت اشتغلوا بشكل ممتاز جدًّا
على موضوع التراخيص
وأيضًا فيه استثمارات أنا أعرف أنها ضخمة جدًّا
صارت من شركات خاصة في حاضنات الأعمال
احنا دورنا ماهو دور كسر الأسعار أو التأثير عليها
احنا دورنا بنعومة ندخل، ونغيّر مع الوقت
وهذا هو اللي صاير اليوم
أعتقد أن وجودنا أحدث زخم كبير جدًّا
اليوم اللهم لك الحمد، فرع الرياض كفرع يُعتبر
هو الأكبر في الشرق الأوسط
اليوم فيه ست فروع مرتبطة فعليًّا مع بعضها البعض
منتصف السنة القادمة يبكون فيه سبعة عشر فرع تقريبًا
ضمن بيئة افتراضية كاملة، وكل فرع فيه مقهى
كل مقهى فيه شاشات، يقدرون أيضًا في المقهى
أو داخل الفرع يعرفون أيش اللي قاعد يصير في خميس مشيط
جادّة خميس مشيط وللا جادّة تبوك وللا غيرها
هذا مبعث فخر الحقيقة
أن احنا صار عندنا اليوم حاضنات ضخمة بهذا الشكل
وفيها اشتراكات مختلفة للناس اللي يبغون يشتركون فيها
يقدر حتى هو يأخذ اشتراك من بريدة ويجلس في تبوك، إلى أخره
تصنيفات معينة إن شاء الله راح تُطرح
لاحظت صراحةً نشاط جدًّا إيجابي لكم في المدن غير الرئيسية
واللي فعلًا فيها الحاجة الأكبر لبرامجكم وخدماتكم
أتذكّر كنت العام الماضي في الجوف
في عزيمة مع شباب الجوف وروّاد أعمالها
فكل واحد منهم أسمع منه قصته
كثير منهم كانت قصتهم مرتبطة بالبنك
حتى مدير الفرع حقكم في الجوف كان حاضر
وكانت علاقته جدًّا رائعة
حبّيت نوع العلاقة اللي صايرة بينه وبين شباب الجوف
وهذا يعكس صراحةً قيمة مثل هذه الأنشطة في المدن غير رئيسية
اللي ما عندها الزخم والحِراك اللي صاير في الرياض
والتشبّع اللي ممكن تشوفه في المدن الرئيسية
بس أنا أتذكّر قبل ثلاث سنوات
أعلنتوا عن اتفاقية مع هيئة عسير
على حدود مليار ريال لمشاريع سياحية في عسير
هذا النوع من التخصص في كل منطقة حسب نقاط القوة جيد
بس فيه ملاحظات على أن ما فيه شيء صار
من هذا المليار هذا كم صرفتوا؟ وكم شركة طلعت؟
فيه جدل على أنه ممكن ما صار شيء
ودّي أفهم منك، أيش الأسباب؟
بالنسبة للجوف حلوة لن أتعدّاها
لأن اليوم الصباح وأنا جاي
مجموعة البنك شاركونا بقصة نجاح لـ«نُزل»
غرّدت عنه الحساب حق «واس جودة الحياة»
فاتح مزرعته حوّلها إلى نُزل وحديقة طيور
وصراحةً أنا ودّي كل واحد يشوف المقطع هذا
العميل هذا من عملاء البنك، رغم أنه ما أشير في هذا
وكثير من عملاءنا يتكلم عن قصة نجاحه دون الإشارة للبنك
وهذه سياسة الإعلام عندنا في البنك
نحاول نخلّي العملاء هم اللي يتكلمون
تستاهلون
فكان الحقيقة في الجوف أهنيّهم وأبارك لهم
عندهم أكثر من فكرة رائعة جدًّا
وفيه المقهى الثقافي
اللي برضه في الجوف موجود، مقهى فريد من نوعه
وممتع، وجرعة ثقافية
فاز بجائزة هيئة الأدب وللا لا؟
فاز مرتين، وجرعة كافيين ممتازة بعد، وغيرها
الجوف عندها إنتاج ممتاز جدًّا للأفكار
عسير عندهم استراتيجية
للشركات والمشاريع الكبرى الموجودة
وتكون مدعومة للمشاريع الصغيرة
وسمو الأمير «تركي» الحقيقة جدًّا نشيط
اجتمعت أنا معه ثلاث مرات حقيقةً مشكورًا
ومشكورًا أيضًا سمو الأمير
رحنا احنا معاه كجزء من جولة
لخمس أماكن أو السبع أماكن
اللي كان فيها البرامج الضخمة اللي راح تكون موجودة فيها
احنا تحمّسنا كثير وأصرّينا أن نكون جزء من هذا الحِراك
وأنا جدًّا سعيد أنها الحمد لله اُعتمدت استراتيجيتهم
والمخصصات أيضًا اُعتمدت
والبنك ترى بدأ في المشاريع هذه
أول بدايات البنك كانت من سنة تقريبًا
فتحنا جادّة، «جادة ثلاثين»
لا أتكلم عن مليار ريال لتمويل مشاريع سياحية
هذه ما صار فيها شيء
المنطقة، بس من بيحتضن المشاريع السياحية؟
من بيتكلم معهم؟ إلا ناس مختصين في الشركات الناشئة
ومختصين أيضًا بالمسرعات اللي هم موجودين في خميس مشيط
أنا أقصد اللي حمّسنا أكثر نفتح في خميس مشيط
الجرأة اللي في خميس مشيط وفي أبها
اللي تتمثّل في هذه المشاريع كلها
احنا مجدولين افتتاحًا لجواد
تزامنًا مع الحِراك اللي صاير في المناطق وفي المدن
فيه شيء تحقق في عسير وفي أبها
بالنسبة على مستوى المشاريع الصغيرة
وإن شاء الله تعالى يتزامن بشكل أكبر مع المشاريع الكبرى
أنا بنتقل لمجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
بأخذ يمكن ثلاثة أسئلة لأن أغلبها غطّيناها في محاور حديثنا
رضا العملاء يبدو لي أن نسبة الرضا ماهي جيدة
أيش مزعلهم؟ أظن أن اللي اطّلعت عليه 15% غير راضين جدًّا
ويمكن 5% غير راضين
فأنت تتكلم على 20% غير راضين
نسبة مرة عالية
السنة هذه عندنا شيء جديد صراحةً أثّر على موضوع الرضا بهذه النسب
اللي هو حجم الطلب
حجم الطلب أنا أعتقد أنه زاد 40% - 50% مقارنة بالعام الماضي
والظاهرة هذه احنا نقلناها أيضًا للصناديق الأخرى
ونقلناها بوضوح للقطاعات أخرى
فيه حِراك غير مسبوق
فيه حجم طلب عجيب الحقيقة اللي قاعد يصير
وما زالوا الزملاء حقيقية في مرحلة البحث
أنا أعطيك مثل
احنا فتحنا منصة، المنصة هذه العميل يسجّل فيها
ويسجّل معلوماته الأساسية، اهتماماته
وليش يبغى مشروعه؟ وإلى آخره
يعطينا معلومات أساسية عنه
اختيارية المنصة هذه
خلال ستة أشهر تقريبًا سجّل فيها أكثر من 750 ألف واحد
وهذولي كلهم فريدين، يعني كلهم رابطينهم بنفاذ
ما فيه تكرار وكلهم اختياريين
التسجيل اختياري مش إلزامي
حجم الطلب اللي جانا على المنشآت
زيادة 40% خلّانا احنا ما نقدر نخدم إلا 15% فقط من العملاء
فبقية العملاء الحقيقة فيه انزعاج مآخذينه اليوم احنا بعين الاعتبار
فيما يتعلق بالموازنات
احنا اللهم لك الحمد أخذنا موافقة على 34 مليار
للأعوام 2023، 2024، 2025
الـ 34 مليار منها 24 مليار مخصصة للقروض الإنتاجية
نعتقد إن شاء الله أننا راح نبني حالة كويسة
والحالة هذه راح تساعدنا على أن نزيد الموازنة حقتنا
في عام 2024- 2025 و راح نلبّي حجم الطلب الموجود
كيف رضاك على موضوع التعامل مع الملاحظات والشكاوى؟
لأن مثلًا وصلتنا تغريدة في بداية السنة هذه
كمثال فقط «محمد الحطيم» يقول
الأخوة في بنك التنمية هل يُعقل طلب إعفاء
عن متوفي مستوفي الشروط يستغرق أكثر من شهرين؟
رغم محاولات تقديم عدة بلاغات هاتفية
وعن طريق الموقع ولكن لا يوجد إجابة
كل المتطلبات موجودة، ولكن للأسف لا يوجد مراعاة لذوي المتوفي
هل من مجيب؟
واحد متوفي شهرين كاملة حتى يستكمل إجراءه؛ فيه تحدي
إذا هذا مثال على شكوى لواحد متوفي وواضحة الحالة
فما بالك بالشكاوى الأخرى!
كيف رضاك على إدارة الشكاوى؟
شوف موضوع الشكاوى ككل
موضوع خاضع عندنا احنا لاتفاقية مستوى الخدمة داخلي
ومتعدد المستويات بالنسبة لاتفاقية مستوى الخدمة
ويصل للرئيس في حال نسب التأخر وصلت إلى حد معين
بالنسبة للمتوفين على فكرة، المتوفين البنك
وكان هو أول جهة أطلق خدمة التأمين على الوفاة
وربطنا احنا مع خدمة «نذير»
فحالات الوفاة اللي تصير احنا نعلم عنها ترى
قبل لا يجي الطلب من العملاء
ونشتغل على موضوع التسويات الداخلية
ونجهزها بحيث يتم إعفاء القرض هذا
للحادثة هذه تحديدًا
قبل لا يجي العميل ويقدّم علينا
طيب ليش أنا قعدت شهرين؟
ما أعرف والله، بالنسبة للعملاء هذه ربما يكون فيه خطأ من عندنا
أو فيه تأخر، يحتاج نشوف الحالة
بس أنا أعرف جيدًا أن احنا ما عندنا شكاوى كثيرة
بالنسبة لوضع المتوفين
قطعًا عندنا ارتفاع كبير في حجم الطلب
وعندنا انزعاج في حجم الطلب العالي
بالنسبة للمتوفين، لا
عندنا أيضًا بين فترة وفترة يصير فيه تأخر في بعض طلبات الإقراض
ويطلع منها مشاكل لو، لا سمح الله حصلت تقنية فنية
خلل فني أو خلافه
وعشان ننصفكم، وعشان مو كل شيء يكون سلبي
يبدو أن في عدد الشكاوى ومدة الإغلاق فيه تحسّن
كان معدل 700 شكوى شهريًّا
وتتجاوز معالجتها عشرة أيام عمل
اللي حاصل حاليًا أنها صارت ثلاثين شكوى شهريًا
وتستغرق أربعة أيام عمل
فهذا تقدّم ملحوظ بس يمكن بعض الحالات ما كانت
الله يسامحنا الأخ محمد، وإن شاء الله...
لأنه ذُكر اسمه يجب أني أرجع وأشوف
جزاك الله خير
سؤالي الأخير أبو حمد على موضوع تكاملكم مع المنظومة
فيه شعور بأن كل شيء تسوونه لحالكم
بينما قد يتضاعف الأثر إذا تم التشارك مع الآخرين
برامج دعم المنشآت مع البنك المنشآت أو مع هيئة المنشآت
في موضوع إقراض المنشآت الصغيرة
اليوم فيه منشآت صغيرة متخصصة في الإقراض
وعندها النظام، وعندها البنية التحتية مثل «منافع»
وزي «إندو» وغيرهم
ليش ما يصير الإقراض من خلالهم؟
لاحظت كثير من الصناديق التنموية والبنوك التنموية
تعتمد على البنوك التجارية في العمليات
وهم يقومون بدور الضامن أو الكفيل أو اللي يغطّي التكلفة
أيش فلسفتكم في أنكم كل شيء قاعدين تسوّونه لحالكم؟
عندنا خليط احنا من الاتفاقيات
واللي احنا نجيد عمله بشكل مباشر
وعندنا البنية التحتيّة اللازمة له
والتكاليف حقها قليلة علينا احنا نسوّيه بشكل مباشر
بينما إذا كان الأمر يتطلّب وجود شريك
سواءً للاستفادة من خبرته، أو لخفض التكاليف
تلقائيًا احنا نوقّع مع الشركاء
عندي يمكن بجيبها من زاويتين
شوف البنك من أوائل البنوك اللي سوّى رأس مال استثماري في البداية
اللي هي صندوق الرياض تقنية
البنك هو يملك الحصة الأكبر
أوه!
في صندوق الرياض تقنية
البنك هو أيضًا أول...
أنتم شركاء في «فودكس» معناته؟
احنا شركاء في كثير
إيه
«فودكس»
عرفنا أرباحكم من وين جاية
«شور» وغيرها إيه
ما شاء الله
البنك كثير يشتغل بصمت
والبنك برضه عنده شركاء
من الشركات اللي أنت ذكرتها
يمكن  ست أو سبع شراكات قائمة وموجودة
عنده شراكات مع «جيديا»
شراكات مع «شور» شراكات مع «هلا» «بيهايف» وغيره
ونعتمد احنا عليهم، يساعدوننا في الوصول للعملاء
في التخصصات اللي هم يفهمون فيها
فموجود، لكن الحقيقة البنك عنده مكينة عظيمة للإقراض
البنية التحتيّة للبنك، والبنية البشرية للبنك اليوم
تُعتبر فاعلة جدًّا وسريعة جدًّا
العملاء أيضًا، العميل يجي يقدّم على بنك التنمية الاجتماعية
يفرق معه أنه يقدم على إكس تقنية مالية الموجودة
التكنولوجيا المالية كلها مرحلة التكوّن اليوم
ما بعد وصلت لمرحلة الثقة مثل البنوك التجارية
هذا جانب، الجانب الثاني البنك الحمدلله
بسبب بنيته التحتيّة الموجودة صار هو أصلًا مشغّل للبرامج
صاروا يُسند لنا احنا تشغيل البرامج
البنك احنا نشغّل مبادرة تمويل غير مباشر
اللي أسسها هيئة منشآت
بتوجيه ولي العهد، وكان عناية كبيرة من معالي «ماجد القصبي»
احنا نشغّل أيضًا لـ صندوق الألعاب الإلكترونية فوق 200 مليون
مشغّلين كاملين لها احنا
واحنا أيضًا مشغّلين لبرنامج تنمية تقنية المعلومات
أيضًا 200 بالإضافة لـ 100 مليون تقريبًا
احنا المكينة اللي تشغّل هذه
فالاستعانة بمصادر خارجية بالنسبة لنا فكرة جيدة
إذا كان فيها قيمة مضافة بالنسبة لنا
شكرًا لك أبو حمد
أنا سعدت بهذا الحوار
الله يعافيك
وبالتوفيق في دعم الناس للانتقال من الرعوية إلى التنمية
إن شاء الله بس ما تفلسفنا كثير
لا بالعكس
بس أنا مستغل سقراط
إيه والله بالعكس
أقعد أتفلسف
تفلسف على راحتك
الله يحييك يا أبو حمد
الله يبارك فيك، شكرًا لك
تسلم
شكرًا لكم. شكرًا لفهد القصيّر في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
ياسر كدشة مساعد إضاءة
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي إدارة الإنتاج عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج رزان الدهيثم
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع